- One a.m.
Greatest night ever.
(upbeat music)
- Check, check, one, two.
Scoo-dee-be-deep-beep.
♪ Me and Mike Boyd in
the back seat, woo. ♪
(upbeat music)
- Have a good day.
- Real good.
A lot of client stuff, a lot of stuff,
just fucking,
we're so busy.
Like it's just like a hyper.
You know like in a video game
where you're going real fast,
but then you have the boost
button and your like ah.
- Sonic the Hedgehog?
- That's the shit where we're on.
How are you, man?
- I'm good, man.
- What's been going on?
- Ah, chillin.
Got the Habu video,
I don't know if you've seen it yet.
- I did, man.
I promised you I'd look at it.
I really liked it, man.
I thought it was fresh.
You saw we put some joints on our,
our playlist this week?
- No.
- Do you listen to our playlist?
- He might not know...
You know what's funny?
We haven't really hit
it that hard just yet.
We started something pretty cool.
- Ah, man, that's fire.
- And you know what's funny?
- Hm?
- I asked a couple people in the office
what their favorite songs were,
your fucking songs.
- Ah, shit, man.
- So I start this,
I start this playlist.
- Uh huh.
♪ Honestly I think that
24/7 an understatement ♪
♪ To my day to day ♪
♪ If ain't no way ♪
- This notion of--
- Thank you.
This notion of, like, my concern
that you have a little bit
too much perfection in you.
- Yeah.
- What do you think?
Like on some friend shit,
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I really think it's a big deal, man.
I really wish I could convince you
but, like, look you're an artist.
So, like, I'm not trying to convince,
but I think it's a healthy conversation.
Like I think I'll
probably drill it into you
every time we know each other
for the rest of our lives.
I don't think artists reali--
Like, I'm so good at one thing.
Which is like the reality of attention
and how shit happens, that's all I got.
It's disproportionately--
like, the shit that I
believe on this issue.
Fuck, man.
- I mean, I be learning something
just through like watching
everything you've been doing
since, you know, we--
- Since we connected.
- And stuff like that.
And, like, I'm definitely like--
- If you're more open-minded to it
than you were before.
Yeah, and it's a process.
Do you consume music?
- Yeah.
And you're like,
like who do you listen to right now?
- Like a lot of alternative
and borrowed stuff.
So like Hiatus Coyote and--
- You need to collab--
you need to literally DM them
and be like, yo we should work together.
- Yeah.
- No, no,
I mean every time anybody
puts out a joint that you like
because my theory is that is
some like fucking country star
or some up and coming
rapper that Boyd puts you on
or some, whatever, alternative.
Or some fucking Bangladeshi kid
that you think did some fly shit.
The reason I say that is my hope
is that like one out of every ten's like,
yo what's up, let's do
it, I'm coming through.
Let's go in studio.
People need to put out music, man.
So, Boyd, what's going on?
- What's going on?
He was saying he'd like to go to Atlanta
and see the studio culture there.
He told me that he only records
when it's time for an album.
I was like I've never even,
I've never seen that, man.
(laughs)
Cause in Atlanta you know everyone.
Here's Atlanta:
Monday through Sunday, studio.
Doesn't matter, you know what I mean?
It doesn't matter if your album...
Like Jeezy, his album drops Friday.
You know what he's doing
when he gets back to Atlanta?
Studio.
That's just like a way of life, you know?
- Mmhmm.
- And you know what
Richie's doing right now?
He's with Future in the studio.
Every day.
- For years, like,
I think I'm doing a lot more.
Like, there's like shit that I wanna do
when I finish--
- You're an interesting guy
cause you're like, you're
also a little bit of like--
You just beat me to it.
You're a little bit of
like a holistic artist.
- Yeah, like, I think
I'm gonna do FoodCon.
I think that they almost set that up
cause they're doing it in
Queens before our sales
and, like, I get to curate all the food
that is coming from Queens.
To, me, like--
- I think you're--
- It doesn't have to always be an EP--
- I also think.
I also think your food joint is real.
I'm sorry, your merchandise is real.
- Thank you.
- I think you got a good eye for that.
- Thank you, man.
- Yeah, man, I think
about it the same way.
I put out a fuck...
I put out a mix tape this week.
The Airplane Project.
(upbeat music)
Man, you're a real tar--
you're a real talented artist, man.
You need to put out music.
- I feel you.
- But you need to figure out
the key is the normal format
isn't gonna work for you this minute
because of the way you think about it.
- Right.
- Like, I'll give you a good example.
- Okay.
- In business, there's shit
that I spend months on thinking
about, putting together.
I pop it out and it
doesn't click in 24 hours
and I know it's not gonna
be what I want it to be
and I'm literally onto the next shit.
And that's a whole different like mindset
where you're just completely deploy
the obnoxious humility of the market
is the market is the market.
- Yeah.
- Game over.
All I know is that like
I'm very interested in
the collaborations of
people that you admire
or you're into it.
- Mmhmm.
- Cause I think there's something there.
What you need to do is create a system...
Hold this.
You need to create a system
where you get the leverage
with the end consumer
so those fucking guys come to you
instead of you worrying about or debating
or being curious of what would happen if.
Let me tell you something else
that I'm gonna really fucking
unleash you right now.
Cause it's gonna really matter.
Let me tell you the biggest
mistake you're making
in your mind from afar on kites.
- Okay.
- You put it on wax.
You put real shit that
you know means something
to your culture on wax.
What you don't realize yet
is you could say the same shit 79 times
over the next nine years in
different contexts and ways
and still pull it off.
There's nothing in the Airplane Project
I haven't said before.
That's why DRock didn't understand it.
Cause he's like, I know this.
It's just a less polished version
of great shit you've said before.
That's why I understood his reaction.
The difference was the way
I packaged the thoughts
I knew would penetrate.
- Absolutely.
- The fact that you could basically make
Cleopatra all over again
and call it Brown Princess in 18 months
on some, whatever the
emerging EDM fucking joint is,
that, my man, is liberating.
- I guess for me it's--
- Do you understand?
- Yeah.
- Because I think that
fucked with me a lot.
Which is like, but I already talked
about patience in a video two years ago.
Until I realized, yeah
but if nobody heard it,
nobody heard it.
Sometimes it's the fourth project
of the same exact shit.
There's so much you could do, man.
- Nah, man, I--
- You could do so much.
- Yeah.
- You could do
so much powerful shit.
Look what happened yesterday.
You could social commentate on that.
- Yeah.
- From a different perspective
that might just be the moment.
- Mmhmm.
- You could or you may
decide to let it pass.
That's all cool.
Tomorrow you may fall in love, like,
there's just so much.
I don't know.
- Yeah, there's so many
ideas I have that are like--
- That's what...
Honestly, when I hear that.
That's where the shit
stops and ends for me.
- Yeah.
- Of course.
If you have ideas, you need
to figure out a process
to get em to fucking
see the world otherwise.
I literally think the
hundred greatest songs
of all time never happened.
They just passed from John Lennon's head.
Like, right?
Michael Jackson just didn't put it on wax.
Dude, the biz dev?
The distribution is more
or equally important
to the actual song when people think...
People think they're
gonna make a hot joint
and somehow miraculously
RapCaviar is gonna pick it up,
everybody's gonna see it and away it goes.
What is your...
Step back now that we got a few minutes,
how do you think about songs?
What are your seven or
80, like how do you...?
What's your process?
- I'm not like a rapper's rapper, right?
So it's not a two track
and just get in the studio
and make a new song like Atlanta does.
They knock out like four,
five, six songs like that.
And also, that doesn't
necessarily interest me.
- Good.
- And I don't like doing shit
that doesn't interest me.
- You shouldn't.
- Cause I'm good at it, right?
Like I could do a...
I could make a blues
song tomorrow if I wanted
and I could make a power song another day,
which is the (hums).
The next day, if I wanted to.
But it doesn't necessarily mean I should.
I'm talented enough to do
all of that shit, right?
But I don't necessarily like making
like straight rap music
or things like that.
My whole MO is making interesting music
like using the artists that I'm into
like Hiatus Coyote and people that I
really, really am fond of.
- Yep.
- And for me, that takes time, right.
That's the process, that's the
ideas that I start creating
like, you know, Tides or Cleopatra,
one of your favorite songs.
That took time in my head.
I needed to produce that in my head.
I was like how the fuck do
I make a dance hall rhythm
and put an Indian sample on it
but it not be the lead?
How do I do that without like...
If you took the sample out,
is it still a good song?
How do you do that?
Because in history of anybody
sampling Indian music,
Indian flute, Timbaland, whatever...
You take the sample out, the song's dumb
it's just a fucking bass drum.
That's what it is.
And because I think
about music that deeply,
you know it's just not like a simple like,
oh I can make a song about cake cannoli
cause that's what I wanna do.
You know what I'm saying?
Because I don't think
about music like that
and it's layered--
- I understand.
- It takes me a longer time to make.
Like I was listening to
Coldplay's Parachutes
this entire week and I was like,
oh I'm taking shit from this.
I'm about to take like alternative shit
and mix it with like trap drums
and then sprinkle in like
the foreign shit that I do.
Just because for me,
that's more interesting.
I could wake up tomorrow and do a...
- What about?
What about, what about...
What about the second
you're done hearing that
and you've decided that,
what about whipping out your phone,
hitting the memos app
and just talking about what's
going on through your mind
and put it out?
- Oh, that's cool.
- What about fucking sharing the process?
- That's cool, yeah.
- Right?
Like what about that?
- Yeah.
- That's unique.
Like what I think...
You know one thing
that's interesting about
that I'm starting to try
to understand about myself
is like I started a longform
YouTube show in 2006.
- Yeah.
- Like.
Like Google flew me out in 2006
and was like what are you doing?
Like I don't...
Like obviously I'm thinking about it a lot
because of the Airplane Project like
I make different shit, man.
DailyVee's different.
DailyVee's the start of a genre.
Like everybody vlogged
before like first person.
People didn't have a dude
fucking following them.
Do you know what's interesting to me?
Is about how I think about things
meaning, so I hear something like that.
I'm like that's so
creative, that's so right
and then I think about leverage.
Thank you.
Right?
I think about leverage.
I think so much of what I do
is to have so much leverage
that when I cash it in
something good happens, right?
Like to me you're a foregone
conclusion success wise.
- To you I'm what?
- Foregone conclusion.
You will be successful.
It's a foregone conclusion.
Who makes a bigger impact?
The artist that stays true the whole way
and then gets put on later in their career
or the artist that,
not deviates or sells out but--
- The first one.
- Breaks out.
- I'll cut you off right
now, the first one.
- Go ahead.
- Every single time.
When you said legacy over--
- Yeah, currency.
- Currency, that's it.
- Well, listen, here's
something interesting though.
Let me tell you something, though.
The Beatles.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- Like to me, I'm fascinated
by do you gather the attention
and then deploy it?
So it's funny, I--
- I feel like
only you're doing it, right?
(background noises drown out conversation)
- Well, it's interesting.
I'm actually going to a weird place maybe
because I was at a charity
event a couple of hours ago.
I used to think, like, ten years ago
that I would make a lot of money one day
and I'd be a really good guy
and be one of those old
guys giving out money.
And now I just give out
money along the way.
And then there's something about like,
the thought of like making an impact
that I wonder if like...
You think about Gaga or Eminem
or things of that nature.
Look at what Eminem's doing right now.
He's making a real...
He has a real chance
to make a real impact.
He's going at it right now.
In like a real smart way.
And like...
I don't know.
There's something so incredible
when you have people listening.
Actually, oh shit.
- There he comes.
- Hello.
- Hello, Hasan.
- How's life?
- It's good, man.
- Loved having you on, man.
- Dude, it was so fun.
- People are loving it so much.
We're getting such good feedback.
- Really?
I feel like the internet
is just exposing people.
- People don't wanna fucking face facts.
People don't want to face facts, man.
We're getting exposed at scale.
People blaming social
media, it's laughable.
- Dude, I think this is bad, though.
I mean, this is ...
A lot of this is not.
- So what's better?
- I would say the same--
- Hiding?
- No, I would just...
No, no, no, no.
- I know we're talking.
- I would just say let's like,
let's strike the balance.
I'll say for me.
- I don't know,
you're the only one that felt that way.
- I'll give you a prime
example right here.
We're having, we're all
chopping it up having dinner.
Like the biggest thing
for me and just like you,
you have to make really,
really big important decisions
and all that stuff.
And so one of the things that I try to do
you know, is just be
logged out of my accounts
until it's time to post.
You know what I mean?
Like that, that...
- By the way, I think that's phenomenal.
- Yeah.
- Here's my thing,
everybody needs to do....
Everybody needs to do their own thing.
Like I just don't understand
what the difference is
between fucking reading
a stream on the bus
where amongst people
or like the person who's
reading the newspaper.
We consume content.
- That is a huge difference, bro.
When we would watch
fucking the NBA on NBC (hums).
- Yeah.
- You wouldn't also--
- I was gonna steal it.
- You wouldn't also be looking
at booty photos,
you wouldn't also be
listening to the radio,
doing all those things.
You just wouldn't do it.
Bro, I'm saying for myself.
- I'm listening.
No, I'm listening.
- I felt that thing.
I felt that ADD anxiety.
- And?
- You know and I've been like,
alright you gotta...
Look, it's a push platform, log out.
You gotta be about your jokes right now.
You gotta be about your pitches
and your show right now.
Don't, don't be going go down that rab...
Rabbit hole is a real rabbit hole.
- That rabbit hole was consumed
by something else in the past.
This notion that we were
miraculously more productive
in 1964 is a huge farce.
The end.
We just did different things.
We romanticize reading a book
or like watching The Cosby Show.
Like I fucking sat on my fat ass
and played fucking Mike Tyson's Punch Out
for an hour and a half,
then watched fucking The Facts of Life,
Three's Company, like it's just--
- You wasted time, but you're
doing one thing at a time.
Which is why I think anxiety was less.
You were still wasting time, bro
and getting Ds and Fs.
- That's fine.
(chuckles)
- It's true.
- But you're doing one thing,
you know what I mean?
- Anxiety is not an all time high.
We're just having a proper
conversation around anxiety.
People have always had anxiety.
- How do you feel about this, man?
You're in your bed,
the first thing you do is
you don't look at your girl
or whoever, you look at this.
- Yeah, no--
- Come on, bro.
- No, no, no, I'm with--
- You're selling, you're selling.
Let him answer, you're like,
you're leading the witness, bro.
- Typically before every
time before I go to sleep,
I find myself saying
why the fuck can't I stop
scrolling down Twitter
and just go to bed.
I think as a habitual,
I'm fascinated by...
Habitual, like, habitual acts and
so basically plugging
your phone in 30 seconds
before I consciously am
realizing what I'm doing.
So from a habitual aspect,
but I also agree that
the habit would just be somewhere else.
- A yellow pad?
When I see yellow pads, I
think smart shit's happening.
- Bro, this is why.
This is my two cents,
if you're an artist and
you're doing this...
No, it's, your life has to be this.
- Me as an artist,
thinks that the fact that my man here
put a medium at a pedestal is sad.
The difference between
this and that is zero,
it's what's on it.
- Is it weird that I'm doing this?
- No, you're like a comic
that works out onstage.
- No, no!
You're better than this in his language.
- Oh. (laughs)
- In his language, yours
is more pure and historic.
To me it's all the same shit.
- You write in your head?
- I'm gonna start writing in my head
cause I think it's fucking cool.
- But then you read like Eminem's book
and that shit was like to the bri...
I'm saying whatever your style
is, is your style, right?
That's fine.
I'm saying this new, this...
Bro, like, by the way
I'm not gonna front as if I'm not in 2017.
I mean, let's be real like
I'm not fucking around.
- It's Google Docs for days.
- I mean come on, man.
We got new takes, we got old takes.
I mean this just...
This is forced.
I mean it really is just nerd
(background noises
drowns out conversation)
- Yo, I think we should go to that tree
and carve some of our thoughts into it.
(laughs)
- Come on, man.
- Engrave them in a--
- Yeah, that's how,
that's the more.
We put mediums on pedestals
instead of what's actually
being put on those mediums.
- You have been able to
use social media for...
You wield it very--
- My love for
social media is zero.
- I, a lot of times, am like
fuck, I'm inside too
much using too much tech
blah blah blah.
I'm on it, fucking it catches me in it,
I'm in a loop, why am I doing this?
I just wanna be outside in
the park, da da da da da.
But then I'm like,
well then I can just go
fucking do that if I want.
So that's always my go back to it.
But there's...
Majority of the days, I find myself saying
I'm fucking sitting here
in front of this computer.
- Yeah, and by the way--
- I don't know what the true
(mumbles) I wanna be outside.
I wanna be camping,
- Yeah.
- I wanna be fucking at the grand--
- We can evolve and
present healthier choices.
- Anti-technology propaganda.
- Dude, this was our shit
our whole life growing up
and now people are like this is,
refined sugar's bad.
- My man, my man, my man.
- There's a healthier alternative.
- You can--
- Y'all sound like
y'all talking about each, either or.
- You guys, you can have both.
Here's my thing, you're in control.
Do you.
But don't shit on the
other person's thing.
Like I'm not judging anybody else's.
Like my whole thing for a lot of people
is like people keep
throwing things at me like,
yo this, this, this.
I'm like cool, but I'm never like yo.
Like I'll never start like
yo, why you putting the paper
and the envelope on a pedestal?
I'm just responding,
I'm counter punching on this issue.
Like to me, life's about choices.
I think the thing super interesting about
social or digital what have you is
first of all, I bet you
everybody at this table
agrees that ten years from now,
we're deeper into the tech.
We're not further away.
- Yeah.
- Now do I think they'll
be some cool hipster
counter-cultural like yo,
I'm on a 500 day detox
I haven't been on, of course.
Because anything that swings,
it's like social itself.
Facebook and Twitter were open,
Snapchat came along and
people are like yeah.
You know, it just swings.
But the punchline is
this entire conversation for me
is the continuation of the
gross underestimisation
of the human being.
We are so much more capable,
like anxiety hasn't
happened because technology.
Anxiety's happening because
we're evolving in the conversations.
The conversation around alcoholism
40 years ago was a disaster.
Like, we're finally
having good conversations
around mental health.
Like I'm thrilled we talk about it more.
Like there was, guys,
you know how many people?
Guys, bullying isn't a
phenomenon on social media.
Bullying's a phenomenon of parents
creating fake realities for children.
There's a lot of variables
that go into this,
it's not just one thing.
I mean, when I was kid.
Bullying, like, your parents
are getting so involved now
that you feel they need
to help you out of it,
not you work yourself out of it.
Now kids have diseases
and bullying's extreme,
I got it but like this
thought that like...
that like, we're not looking
at the counter angle to this.
So for example, the amount
of kids that are happy today
at 14 because they got
their friends on Twitch
that literally 20 years
ago would've been miserable
and would've been sick and
would've been depressed
cause everybody at school fucked with them
and they didn't have
somewhere to go like Twitch
to find their own.
We're just looking at the negative,
we're not looking at the pro.
Here's what I think,
on the biggest macro and then
everything else is secondary.
We were full of shit
and it's time for the
fucking day of reckoning
and, by the way, we're in the beginning.
Shit's about to get way worse.
- Be specific.
I don't understand what you're saying.
- Shit's about to hit
the fan for everybody.
Shit's, we're getting naked.
This is the beginning of us getting naked.
We're systematically
over the next two decades
gonna face our fucking truths
that we don't want to fucking face.
Like, lots and lots and lots of things.
Like, every single issue.
There's nowhere to hide, the media...
The media, whether
controlled by a dictator
or by rich tycoons, was
the filter of our thoughts.
Now everybody's getting exposed,
so like first we have to
face some real truths.
Like, I don't think like...
We're gonna have to face
some real truths, man.
Like we need some real
corrections across the board
and we're just gonna
go through that cycle,
like everything bad is
gonna get out in the open.
- I think misinformation's
happening in scale, though.
We're not having enough
correct correction, yeah.
- So misinformation was
always happening, though.
Like let's take that back.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Here's the most different
thing that's happening,
if you have power, you're not safe.
The biggest shift today from 30 years ago
is if you have leverage,
you can't use it to control the narrative.
All we are is the serendipity
of like moments in time.
I think everybody's got a really...
Is gonna struggle because
it's a chemical thing.
Here's what's always been historic,
when you're in the middle of real change,
you're always like what the fuck.
Because you don't have the backdrop to--
- Right.
- Right?
- So we're in the midst of--
- We're in the midst of real change.
The internet's a real...
Like this has been my
whole point the whole time
and you as like the great
historian of my content,
which I appreciate.
Like, I believe in this shit, man.
- (laughs) The great historian...
- Dude, this dude.
Honestly, dude, like I don't know
if I've ever been more humbled.
I'm being dead serious
and like I get flattered,
I'm always pretty happy and surprised.
Whoo, it's fucking, you
know, the 30th you're in it.
- I love it, dude.
- It's so impressive.
(conversations overlap and
background noise drowns them out)
- It makes me think he's super smart
that he's so deep into my content.
- One of the things that I love
like when I was super, when I was like
ah this is great, is
when you do Airport Gary.
(laughs)
Cause you get out on the streets,
you just fucking...
His pants are down, shit
doesn't fit properly,
sometimes the shirt is too short.
- Oh yeah.
- Like that hat.
- And then this is all paste,
but he's fucking hustling.
No excuse and he doesn't care!
And by the way, this
goes back to my point,
in you know our industry...
- Like, everybody's doing dumb shit.
- Everything--
(laughs)
- But everything's set
up for Getty Images.
Bro, everything I know about Future
is his shit is perfect,
his jewels are perf...
Everything's perfect.
- That's true.
- And what I think he's leveraging,
which I think makes him unique,
is that it's like no, it's not like that.
- Here's the best part.
I don't even know it's broken.
I'm, like when I hear these stories,
I get really excited
because it speaks to a real aud--
- Oh, how crazy you look?
I put it on wax.
I'm like you're crazy
but I think you're doing
a lot of good things.
But, yeah, you look kind of
insane in those moments, yeah.
- It's when you don't
understand the actual...
Like it's funny, I hear
stuff and sometimes I'm like
I'm real smart and I really do...
I run the extreme of
being really, really smart
and really knowing it
and then being completely
oblivious to certain shit
and then I'm so on.
And in those two extremes
comes what I think you've sniffed out,
uniquely by the way,
that's what it is.
I don't even know when
I'm doing shit sometimes
and other times I really know.
- What's the macro number, you think?
So is a fundamental good versus evil.
I fundamentally present this issue:
What is bigger, love or fear?
Unfortunately and I'm just
gonna be real with you guys
at the table, is that like, I
feel like fear is like sugar.
It's easier to tap into and
you can scale it faster.
And love is a little bit tougher,
to execute and scale.
- Yeah, but that's how I think.
I agree, I think that's
generally human nature.
- I think Voldemort is slightly
more powerful than Harry.
52 to 48 or 60 to 40.
- I think human nature is
- What app did I just lose?
- Be with the fear
and then give the love
to kind of suppress it.
- So what's the number?
Cause here's the thing,
it's a gray zone, right?
And I think that all that keeps happening
that it's either one or the other.
- I think evil--
- I think it's either all evil
or all love.
I actually think it's the,
what's the series at?
Is it 70/30?
- I think where you had it.
- 60/40? 52/48?
- Yeah, 52/48.
- One thing I posted about
a couple of hours ago.
- Resist, respond and react
to fear, you've lost. (laughs)
- I think, I think ...
I think, I think fear wins in the micro
and love wins in the macro.
- Yeah.
- And I think when
we're in moments of fear,
it feels so not close.
- How bout, how bout...
- And that's what we're in.
What's super interesting to me
is this whole notion that
I really think everybody's famous.
Or the notion of like how
many people you're famous to,
micro fame, like it's just...
The whole thing is being redefined.
Like I think we might've
said in our podcast
like the fact that I genuinely think
the 30 most famous people on Instagram
are unbelievably more famous than
the 30 most famous
people not on Instagram.
Like shit is getting so interesting.
I'm fascinated by how
famous you really need to be
to, like, go somewhere
where a lot of people know who you are.
Like a lot, a lot.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Who's like that?
Like, uh...
- Drake.
- Yeah, Drake, exactly.
Like if Rihanna walks down, Rihanna.
Like you gotta be--
- Can I ask you a question?
- Yeah.
- So.
I think you hang out with
a lot of young people.
- Yes.
- Why is that?
- Um, cause I really think that
this is a very disproportionate time
where the young people of our society
are impacting from the ground up
instead of top down.
- But can I say something?
The reason why I like to hang out with
people who are older than me
is a thing that I don't have, is wisdom.
- I'm the same way.
- Wisdom is like,
bro, wisdom is valuable.
- Yeah, I just like.
I have a lot of wis...
I have a lot of natural wisdom.
(laughs)
- No, no, no, no, no.
- I'm being serious a little bit.
So what's interesting...
You might find this interesting.
This is super interesting,
back to being hardcore about my content,
I don't say it that often.
I spent an unbelievable
amount of time as a kid
with very old people.
Here's what I know
is that we are really,
really bad as a being
of like thinking things
through in a 360 way
when we either like the way
it turned out or we don't.
You know what's funny?
This has been the theme
of our conversation
a little bit tonight,
my favorite thing.
My favorite thing about how
I go through all of this
is I feel when I lose or
things don't go my way
that I truly deserve
it in such a deep way.
When you just talked
about me losing it all,
the only thing when I
talk about that shit,
here's my punchline on that:
if it happens, it should've happened.
I deserved it to happen.
And, like, to me that
I spend a lot of time
thinking about that,
I like when bad things happen cause
I think if I'm gonna enjoy
the fruits of the victories,
I have to learn from the
things that I fucked up on.
You have to respect the game
more than you respect yourself.
Like in a weird way, you
have to respect the game more
than what you want out of the game.
- That was an Omar line.
- What?
- That was an Omar line from The Wire.
- Did you read a lot of
Buddhism books or something?
- No, but I'm sup--
- How did you center your--?
- No, because--
- That takes a lot
of centering.
- Honestly, I'm telling you
right now, it's so interesting
and I've never thought about this.
About the young thing.
I'm like, oh fuck.
While we were talking, the
other part of my brain is like
oh fuck, that's gonna be the punchline.
I spent my first twenty years
with fucking 80 year olds
and when I'm 80, I'm
gonna spend all my time
with 20 year olds, it's gonna get worse.
What I'm doing right
now is gonna get worse.
- Yeah, please don't do that.
It's gonna be creepy.
Wait until you see me at 63 being like,
hey, 14 year old girl, come over here.
(laughter drowns out conversation)
Like that's my, you know.
- No, I know.
(laughter drowns out conversation)
Airport Gary's crazy enough to do that.
He'll be like on his
knees in front of a bag
and be like, you're 13?
What are you watching?
- By the way, by the way, by the way,
it happened even before
I was filming, thank God.
It was when Snapchat was popping.
Snapchat was popping and I couldn't tell,
couldn't see, I didn't know what it was
but I saw, literally, exactly
in the corner of my eye
a couple of times like,
there's some yellow app
that these kids are...
Like that's how I first
knew about Snapchat.
And I went to the app store
and looked for a yellow app.
Nothing.
And I'm like some shit's
going down, that I...
You know what I mean?
You know there's like a party, why am I...
Like you're in dorm and you're like
there's a party I'm not in...
I was like there's something wrong.
So finally, like I caught it.
Like I saw somebody again
and I went in her shit,
she was like 14 and I'm like all in it
and then I look and the dad's like
what the fuck are you doing?
I was like yo.
(laughs)
Sorry.
The first thing that
has always worked for me
is never allowing somebody
to have leverage on you.
- And this shit,
because I didn't want to
fuck with that person.
- That's, me too.
- Cause that was like.
- Good, me too.
- That was like...
- Like, that's great but I don't even...
The key is to like,
I've gotten to the point
where I don't even realize
I'm missing it anymore.
Because it becomes practice.
Honestly, I'll give you a good example.
Look at our table right now.
Do you know how serious
amount of food this is
for so many people around the world?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I know.
I was, yes.
(laughs)
I'm like my parents would be revolted.
- Right?
So I look at this, right?
This is how I look at your question.
There's so much to eat,
you don't need.
- Oh, right right.
- So I don't think like
oh, I better go like...
For you, right?
It's like, oh shit I hate that person
but that person is the
person that plays the record
or that person picks the playlist
for the 84 million person
playlist on Spotify or SoundCloud.
I'm kind of just like, mrr.
I don't even like, I'm like...
To me this is why if you really break down
what I'm always saying,
I'm just like bring so much
value to the end person
so that you have the most leverage.
Amazon gives us the best thing.
We all love Amazon cause it's the best
buying experience, thus Amazon
will kill everybody else
cause they're the best to the consumer.
I want your control of the
thing that most people see
because if you bring the most value,
then you have the leverage.
Everybody comes to me because
I'm giving value at scale
with no expectation of anything else.
Can I tell you something?
I'm gonna give you a real...
Like, something really just hit me.
I think you should shut everything out.
- Do what?
- You should shut everything out.
- I think maybe you could take actually
the passwords off your social and
you know maybe follow
my take on the issue.
- I think you should
keep your passwords on
and just go reply to every single person.
You need to go insular for a year.
You, your shit and your
fans and nothing else.
Truth always wins.
I don't, it's unbelievable how
like I've never had scrutiny at this level
from people I respect
or bigger people than
right this minute going on.
And I've never felt more calm about it.
It's interesting like how momentum--
- You didn't answer my
question about how--
- I apologize.
- How'd you get that attention?
- Because I know what the fuck I'm up to.
Because I know what I'm up to.
Like how I am has a lot to do
with the way I was parented,
how I grew up, a million
different variables.
But in it's current state of the union,
like this second, I just
know how it's gonna play out.
- But I also think he'd be
this confident if he was broke.
He's truly crazy.
- That's what I'm saying.
- Sorry, dude.
He's crazy.
- That's the centered part!
Like I just realized even with good shit,
certain good things happening to me now,
I felt like that shit was gonna fix
some of the problems
or make me feel better.
But, you know, everybody
tells you that shit
but you don't fucking take it in--
- You know what's crazy?
You're lucky you didn't get, pop out
cause that shit would've exposed
and accelerated the negative.
Exposure, like wealth
and people's eyes on you
exposes your truths.
- Mmhmm.
- Money and fame expose who you are,
they don't change...
People are like, oh he changed.
He didn't change.
He was fucked the fuck up, you
just weren't paying attention
cause you didn't give a fuck.
It's also patient.
You know how much I love it, man.
Especially when I'm talking,
when you're talking 24.
Ooh, you have such an advantage, man.
I think people don't believe me, I guess.
- I'm not 24, though.
- How old are you, 27?
- I'm about to be 29.
- But patience, Gary,
- Really? You look great, man.
- Patience is a thing
that comes with wisdom.
(laughs)
- I understand.
- I'm telling you, wisdom
is really important.
- Patience comes with being broke.
- I think a lot of people who are broke
struggle with patience cause they just
want to get the fuck out.
- I agree with you on that.
- I think broke actually creates (sighs)--
- I think it's two ways.
I think you can either take it that way
or you take it as a person--
- And, honestly, man.
Honestly--
- I'm always gonna be with
like this broke shit
- Honestly.
Honestly, this is why I'm
obsessed with positivity
and mindset and parenting.
Like we could debate
this all the way through,
if you're good, you're good.
This shit is so basic, if
you're good you're just good.
Just trying to get people
to be good, you know?
Like, perspective.
- Now I think the big
thing that Super Duper Kyle
and Russ and all these
guys are gonna deal with,
is the same thing Yung
Joc and all those guys
are facing going on is, what
is the thing that you do
to then once you have that moment
to have longevity in that career?
What's your opinion?
- The answer's very simple to me on this.
The truth is undefeated.
Meaning there have been one hit wonders
long before Yung Joc, right?
So--
(laughs)
So my thought,
my thought on this is very
simple, the following:
- Remember that crazy interview,
you talk about I stood in that window
as long as I possibly could?
- Stretch.
- Yeah, he's the longest.
- Yeah.
- Everybody else is--
- We talked about this earlier
when you weren't here, but
let him finish real fast.
- My thought on this is very simple,
perfection scares the fuck out of me.
- You're perfection scared.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- I see so many of my homies,
that's what I'm worried about with you.
And perfection scares the piss...
And I don't know, right?
It just, quick read, I hope it's not that
cause if it's that,
that's real hard to break through.
But yeah, I mean, I think
the truth plays out.
You know, like for
example, Trinidad James.
I'm super intrigued by him right now
because I think he is
like right on the pedestal
of the last decade of
hip hop one hit wonders.
And, like, I'm watching
what he's doing right now
and I'm like interacting
a little bit with him,
I'm like fuck, man, it'll
be really interesting to see
if he's got anything else in the can.
But my big thing is that
being a one hit wonder is better
than being a no hit wonder.
I really do believe that.
Meaning, meaning, it all
comes down to the psyche.
There's people back to being grounded,
back to you saying,
"Gary, you could do
that, but the 99 can't"
with the whole like, right?
Here's my thing, there's people
who've been one hit wonders
or child stars, we focus on all the people
that got fucked up,
we don't look at the macro math.
We focus on the 13%
that couldn't handle it
and exploded in front of our faces
without understanding the 87%.
There was plenty of
stars of Punky Brewster
and Growing Pains that
live nice fucking lives
and like make funny jokes with ea--
- But we focus on Macaulay Culkin.
- Correct, correct.
Like to me, it's like when I talked about
the Sneaker Project, I really meant it.
I don't know if people...
Like, I'm always confused
what people are thinking.
I would've thought it was phenomenal
if we were sitting here in 15 years
and be like, Mm you fucking
thought you could have this...
Like there's nothing more fun
than having your buddies make fun of you
of audacious shit that you've failed on.
Like somebody, like you!
You said something about
planet of the apps,
I was so, I was dying
because what I was like
was like, okay, motherfucker,
I'm literally gonna have
a Netflix fucking special
that's gonna be downloaded more than you,
you fucking comedian.
Like you either have that, right?
(laughs)
- Like you either have--
But this is the truth.
I'm giving you my truth.
You either have that gear
or you're like (hums).
- No, there's no way I'm doing that.
- Right?
There's a prelogue to
the Airplane Project.
- Prologue.
- Prologue, thank you.
There's a prologue where Drock says,
it's not gonna work, but the good stuff--
- Is the verdict out?
- The verdict's out, I won.
Fucking it dominated.
(background noises muffle conversation)
(laughs)
- It's all there!
- The energy that you're
deploying right now
versus the reality of your energy,
which was like audacious post-production
like this isn't gonna work,
nobody wants to hear your
ums and oohs and I'm gonna clean it up
and I'm like, you're not
gonna clean anything.
- I'm with DRock on this.
- Of course you do.
- I think you could still--
- You two Hollywood fuckers.
(laughs)
Do you know what I think
your career would be at
if you threw more non
polished stuff at scale?
You'd be in outer space.
- Okay, okay.
Something I'm considering.
- You're gonna kill that.
No, no, you're not considering it.
You're gonna do it and you're gonna
destroy, fucking destroy it.
- So.
- It's less about that, it's
just about the thought of.
You better start fucking recording memos
when you think about shit about
the process of making songs
and put that shit out.
Just tweet it.
Listening to you like walking
down the street right now
and be like, Cleopatra but
then I'm gonna take the drums
and I was fucking listening
to Coldplay last night
and that new fucking joint
and Mike Boyd said it's on,
there's Rap Caviar, oh shit that remind...
Just (makes exploding noises).
Eight minutes and 13 seconds
of what's going through your dome out.
(exhales)
By the time the song comes out?
Everyone's gonna (makes
buzzing noises), you know?
You're gonna get them on
it before it came out.
My turn, my turn, ready?
For the culture.
For your culture, just put some shit out.
Here's my biggest problem,
stuff has to come out.
Like so many people--
- Why are we debating?
- Yes!
- I mean he's mad right--
- I know I'm right, you know why?
Let's do something for
the culture right now!
You guys ready?
Like, let's fucking go!
Like two brown guys and a white guy.
(laughs)
- Bro, he's ready to go to
Caroline's like right now.
- Like, right now.
Like right now.
Like tonight I was...
You know, but I had the sweet chicken
and you know, here's what I know.
There's so much good that
never sees the day of life.
The end.
- You what the little asterisk
I want to put on Gary's thing
is that like do the grinding shit
and put out your studio shit.
- A hun, by the way,
- That's the--
- You know what I call high-low?
- But that's what we do.
- Oh.
- High-low.
- I missed that track.
I missed that track, aw man.
- High low.
- High low, yeah.
- Don't do shit in the middle.
Do your Netflix special,
but you should be putting out fucking
a one minute video straight
to your fucking face
social commentating on Instagram
called On The Way to Work.
Every day.
I wanna hear...
That would be the only
thing I would consume.
Your hot take on the day.
- More about what I (mumbles).
- I love you, Bama.
That's it, three second video.
There's just, guys, we are so lucky
we have production companies.
We have production
companies and distribution
in our hand for free.
This food.
Do you know what fucking Prince would do
if this fucking existed?
Like are you kidding?
That man, that man fucking--
- Yeah, nah, the memo shit
he said, that was wild.
- Do you know how mad I was
when they found all those songs
in Prince's fucking vault?
Like genuinely mad?
Those things should've
seen the light of day.
- Yeah.
- Imagine, I mean, you
know how much more fun
it would be if we had
57 more Biggie songs?
- Yeah.
- The just the biggest
thing is just like, man,
I don't know.
It's never been a better
time to be an artist
and, like, I still think you're buying--
- Bro, he's just saying
and I'm taking this to heart
as a comedian, max out.
He's our personal trainer,
he's gonna max out.
So I gotta max out this year.
So usually I can write a
new half hour, 45 minutes,
can I do 70?
- Yeah.
- Or, or, or, with the tools of the day...
Ready? Real quick.
- Max out, bro, put some 45s on that shit.
- Let me just say something real quick,
or if the tools of the day...
How many hooks run through
your head in a week?
Okay, cool, great.
- Just being honest.
- No, listen,
I love you for that,
like this is the point.
My big thing is I think
we need to let people
into our process more
because if we do and we put it out
it may lead to the
thing we're looking for.
So for example, I've been
talking about Perfectly Parented,
the book that I've been wanting
to write for like five years
a rare thing for me to be...
I believe in it so much, I'm hyping it,
like this fucking guy
you just told me about.
I feel like I'm hyping
this mystical thing,
I feel like by the time that
I write Perfectly Parented
every parent on earth is gonna buy it.
Yet, the biggest progress I've ever made
in Perfectly Parented was track six.
Was track six.
Was track six the fucking,
the Airplane Project.
Like, it's the first time I really got,
like I started putting some
of the parent stuff on wax.
I'm out.
- Alright, bro.
- Love you.
- Oh my god, so fast.
- So glad we did it.
So glad we did it.
- Yeah, I'm really glad this happened.
You guys got on my (mumbles).
- Oh, we know how to edit this.
DRock knows exactly how to do it.
- One of these days,
I'm pulling him onstage.
(laughs)
It's gonna happen.
- And I'm saying it right now,
I'm gonna fucking make people cry.
They're gonna laugh so hard.
One a.m., greatest night ever.
(chill music)